Hello, everybody! Welcome back
at the next episode of functional
programming 101
and today we are going to talk about
interactive programs. But before we
start
I want to share a story that I
originally heard from Simon Peyton Jones.
Simon Peyton Jones, everybody
should know,
is one of the main drivers behind
Haskell and also
one of the founders of the Glasgow
Haskell Compiler that
we have been using in this course.
Here is the story. In this little box
there is a super powerful quantum
computer.
It's extremely powerful. It can
break every encryption scheme
known to man. It can solve any
problem. It cures cancer...
everything! The only problem is that
it has no I/O. So we will never know
whether this quantum computer works
or not. The moral of this story is that
if your program is not able to
communicate
with the outside world, it might as well
not exist. And if you go back to the
early days of Haskell
it was actually really hard to have a
Haskell program
communicate with the outside world.
Whereas if you use
any other programming language it's
trivial.
The first code we all write is hello world
which prints "hello world"
on the standard output, whereas in
Haskell
that hello world was super complicated.
First we had stream I/O, then we had
continuation based I/O and
finally, and that's what we are going to
talk about today
we have the I/O monad. And with the I/O
monad
Haskell has gotten its I/O port
on the box, such that it can easily
communicate
with the outside world.
So far we have only written programs
that
take some input and return a string
or an integer or a tuple or a list
and we have printed that value
on the output of the
REPL loop, of the GHC interpreter.
But what we really want to do, is we want
to write
programs like most programs, like every
Java program, like every C# program, like
any imperative program, that takes
inputs from the external world, does
something with it
and produces output.
And in fact what we want, is that it
produces output
as it's getting new inputs.
So we want to produce outputs
as we are getting
new inputs. So what this program has to do
it has to interact with the keyboard
and the screen. If we
look at our program as a function
in some sense now it becomes dependent
on the keyboard
and besides just producing output
it also will communicate with the screen.
The problem
is that Haskell programs are
pure functions, which means they cannot
have side effects.
Maybe it is good to
informally talk about
what a mathematical function is.
A mathe..
That's a complex word!
A mathematical function is
a function that when you give it the
same
argument will always give you the same
result.
For example, factorial
when I give it n
it will return factorial n. When I give
it n again
it will return factorial of n again. Now
look at a common function
that we use in imperative programming,
for example
readLine. ReadLine takes no arguments or
the empty tuple and returns a string.
When I call readLine again
with the same arguments, the same empty
tuple, it will return a different string.
So readLine is not a mathematical
function
and the reason is because it has side
effects.
So it will return a string
but there is something there that is not
apparent in the type.
And that's what the I/O monad
solves. The I/O monad expresses
in the type of a function that this
function
has a side effect. So interactive
programs, programs that
interact with the outside world, have
side effects
and we need a way to incorporate side
effects
in Haskell programs.
I don't think that side effects are bad.
Actually they are super useful
because without side effects it is
really hard to write these
interactive programs. But the thing is
that you have to make sure
again it's a balance, it's a question of
taste
how you use those side effects.
It's a little bit like salt or spices
in food.
You can overdo it and your food is too
salty and it doesn't taste well
but if you don't use any salt
your food is also not tasty.
So it is up to you as a developer
to decide how much side effects to use.
But it is never a good answer to say
I'm never going to use side effects
or it is also never good, the other
extreme, to say
I don't care about purity.
That is exactly what shows mastery of
programming
that you can decide where to use side
effects
and where to avoid them. But if I hear
you say
we have to program without any side
effects, you have not
understood the essence of this course.
As I mentioned, the solution to
the problem is to introduce a new type
and we really don't care how this type
is defined.
For now we will just assume
it is some abstract type: IO of a.
And this type denotes an action
that will perform some side effects and
as a result
will return a value of type a.
Maybe a good way to
remember the difference, is that in
Haskell so far we have only used
expressions
but we didn't mention statements, whereas
in an imperative
language there are expressions and there
are statements, where statements
mostly communicate via side effects. And
in some sense by introducing the I/O monad
we are also introducing statements in
Haskell.
Or another way to say that is
we introduce the notion of
actions in Haskell. But these actions
themselves
are also expressions, so they can be
composed. Let's look at some concrete
examples
of the I/O monad. Here is IO of Char
which is the type of an action that will
perform some side effects
and then return a character. And then
the most imperative
of imperative types, that is IO of unit.
That is a function that only performs
side effects.
The only interesting thing it does is
performing side effects.
Because it has no real result value, it
returns the empty tuple.
And in a typical imperative language
this would be the type void. So if you
have a function that returns void
in Haskell that becomes a function that
returns
type IO of unit.
This empty tuple is nothing special.
It's just a tuple that has no
components. Now
that we have this type, and again we
really don't care how the I/O monad is
defined
as long as we have operations
defined on them. So this is a little
bit like
object-oriented programming. We have a
class.
We have methods on that class. And in
order to use
a class, you don't need to know how that
class is implemented.
You just use the methods, and that's the
same thing here
with the I/O monad. And the first operation
that we have
on the I/O monad here is getChar. In
a typical imperative language, getChar
has type
unit arrow char.
In Haskell, because we are lazy, we don't
need the unit arrow.
And so instead getChar is just
something that has a side effect and then
returns a character. If this would
be strict
it would immediately return a character
right there.
But since Haskell is lazy, we don't have to
have this explicit thunk that defers
evaluation.
That's another interesting thing.
In typical imperative languages, whenever
you see a function that has type unit
arrow something, it means that you are
trying to simulate
laziness. Here is another
example. The function
putChar, which writes a character to
the standard output.
It takes a character and it returns void.
It has side effects, but it doesn't
return any
useful value. And then
just like for parsers, we have the
action that immediately returns without
doing anything.
So it takes a value and it immediately
returns that value
without performing
any further side effects. And then
we will be using the same kind of
sequencing that we used for parsers.
And again, in the exercises you will
see how this do notation
is translated in terms of the bind
function. But right now
we will just use the do notation, because
it looks very much like
traditional imperative code. So here is a
function
that reads a character, reads another
character but
ignores the result, and then reads a
third character
and returns the pair of those two. So if
you remember the parsers from the last
lecture
we had more or less exactly the same
example here
except that we used the item parser
three times and here
we are reading a character from the
standard input. We can
define a function using getChar
that reads a string from the standard
input as follows:
we read a character, we call that
character x.
Notice that getChar has type IO of Char
and then x here has type Char.
So the arrow is very similar to the
arrow in generators in list
comprehensions. So there is an
IO of t on the right and then there is
a t on the left of the arrow. And that's
why
we use the arrow symbol and not
the equals symbol, because the type on this
side is different than the type
on that side. If the character that we
just read is
the new line, then we are done
so we return
the empty string. Otherwise we
recursively
read on to read the rest of this
character
and then we return the previous
character that we read
concatenated on the string that we
recursively write.
So another recursive
thing here, where we just
call this thing itself recursively, until
we hit the new line
and then we return all the values. Here
is an example
that takes a string and writes it to the
standard output.
If we have the empty string, we cannot
do anything, so we just
return unit immediately. If we have a
string that starts with a character x
followed by a string xs
we print the first character and
then recursively
we print the rest of the string on the
screen.
This guy here returns IO of unit, so the
whole thing returns IO of
unit and everything fits. Now
we can define
another function that simply combines
putString with putChar
to write a new line behind it, so we
first print the string
and then we print a new line. The beauty
of all this
is that we can mix and match imperative
code or I/O
code with all the functions that we
have defined before.
In particular functions over lists,
because strings are just lists.
So we can imperatively read
a string from the standard input. Then
use regular list
functions on that string and then
imperatively
within the I/O monad write this to the
standard output.
So let's walk through this example. We
print "Enter a string", we read this
line from the input and then we print
that that line has so many characters.
Very simple, but you see here you combine
there's an
island of purity in the sea of impurity.
And this is a perfect perfect perfect way
to program.
So you have little parts of pure code
embedded
in a context of impure code. And when we
run this string length in GHCi
it will print "Enter a string", we
type a string
and it will tell us that this string has
five characters.
Note that this thing is only
evaluated for the side effects. It
doesn't return
a useful value and we see that
because it has type IO of unit. This is
the end of part 1.
See you in a few minutes when we are
continuing to talk about the I/O monad.
Thank you!